dylan ceased his third start the first
one not so good the second one excellent
as that's to first jose spins it to
second return pass double play good
first inning
off walk no harm done well aaron savage
is going to be on the mound for the
indians making his third start he did
beat chicago back on the 28th at the
worst jose wants a fly ball
[Applause]
on the ground to shortstop lindor
hernandez and double play the sox do get
a run
so what's your message if you're don
cooper here just don't worry about the
bases loaded start getting hitters out
throw strike one get ahead of these guys
on two
he struck him out fastball away one gone
out away
good pitch threw it right by him
there's a big first out now you got a
guy that doesn't run at all and if he
hits a ground ball you're out of the
inning one ball two strikes on leon and
the pitch
a ground ball to the third base side
will be tagged the back and makata at
third base he'll sling it across in time
and they get the double play it was
perfectly placed off the end of the bat
and moncada able to tag the bag at third
and wing it across in time for an inning
second base diving stop mending and he
aced him
nicely done danny at second for round
number two getting the jersey dirty
that's a great addition to this ball
club danny mendick with injuries to the
infield
he can play just about anywhere this is
just an outstanding effort
full out dive from his knees gets it
there and again hernandez can run also
and he's got him by plenty
oh he knocked him down and struck him
out
it is literally a knock down drag out
affair
knocked him down now they can drag him
out time to go the next inning
here's the 2-2
swung on a slow chopper to the left side
picked up by montana and he won't have a
play he struggled to handle that ball
and wisely held onto it
so all hands are safe now the bases are
loaded
for jose ramirez bases loaded one
nothing white sox fifth inning and the
pitch
sharply to second fielded there by danny
mendick on to first base in time dylan
sees a masterful job
getting out of the situation that he
kind of created
and he leaves the base
yeah you thought maybe the success they
had offensively last night might carry
over here this evening but it has not
there's a base hit by santana the third
hit of the night for cleveland
and that snaps an 0 for 10 for santana
okay so he's starting he's on two out of
the three times tonight
he's so big and strong he can hit it out
anywhere
stay on it
oh and he walked him so two on one out
they're really pinching up the middle in
the infield
guess why
mendic garcia turn it got him
[Applause]
they're really pinching up the middle on
the infield
back to the mound savali oh low throw
safe
a grenade to first
wow
he is so accurate he's walked one guy
all night long you try to lollipop the
ball
you open the door for
this
1-2
up the middle into center field base hit
oh angle is going to test it and he is
into third adam was churning all the way
and he beats the throw from de shields
this is normally where jose abreu shines
right back by him but look at here a
double play ball
what a job second time tonight he's
gotten to brayu to hit into a twin
killer six complete one-nothing chicago
tops another one and her
slow throw and hey bray you could not
come up with it so bummer spiked that
into the ground
and the indians get another chance
two and two on ramirez pitch high fly
ball into deep right field backing up as
adam angle he's got a beat he makes the
catch just shy of the warning track
a long scary outs but an ounce and
that's all that really matters as the
indian strand a pair here and there
now the 1-2 offering
check swing straight three called locked
them up with a heater
and so aaron savali finishes with his
fifth strikeout
and so the indians and socks go to the
eighth one one-nothing sox
could use
some late magic here and tack on an
insurance runner too
you can see some fastballs he's 63
fastball on the year 25 percent
change-up and this ball's charged up
deep left center adam angle absolutely
crushes the first pitch
and it's two nothing socks
[Applause]
well i'll tell you what you said he's
gonna see some fastballs adam heard that
being an aficionado of the broadcast and
all
waited for the first ball fastball and
took it way out of here his second home
run
on a ball and two strikes with two down
[Applause]
struck him out in the socks shut out
cleveland
big ball game well pitched well played
overall